Russia's Victory
Day celebration this week
marking the Soviet Union's
defeat of Nazi
Germany
in World War
Two may not have seemed restrained
with its columns of troops
standing to attention
marching under the Tricolore.
But it was a muted display.
The Kremlin decided to forgo
the traditional flyover of warplanes
The parade featured only one tank.
More than 20 cities
cancel their ceremonies
at a national march
honoring veterans were scrapped.
Officials cited
security concerns
as the reason for the pared back events.
But President Vladimir Putin
might also have been unwilling
to ostentatiously celebrate
a 78 year old victory
when current news from
the Ukrainian front is bleak.
Best estimates
say that as many as 200,000
Russian troops have been killed
or wounded.
Many troops on the front line
lack proper supplies,
and the Ukrainian counteroffensive looms.
Still, in his speech,
Putin appeared
unbowed by these pressures,
casting himself
as the defender of a country
beset by the censure
of Western globalist elites.
He may
want to start
worrying about his own elites
from the outside.
It's easy to see Putin
as an
all powerful strongman
who rules Russia by decree
and has manipulated and mobilized
his people behind him.
But in a fascinating interview
with Isaac Charlton of The New Yorker,
Tatiana Steno, via
a senior
fellow at the Carnegie
Russia Eurasia
Center, describes
a more vulnerable Putin.
And that is in part
because Russian elites
have begun to grow disillusioned
with his leadership
and fear the outcome
of what they increasingly see
as an unwinnable war.
Stunned, advised
Putin is a leader caught
between two sets of elites.
On the one hand,
there is the progressive elite
made up of technocrats,
regional governors and senior officials
who view Putin as too extreme
and worry
about the effect of Western
economic sanctions.
On the other hand,
there are what she calls
the patriots who see Putin as too soft.
These voices are diffuse and plentiful,
and they include men
such as Yevgeny Preclusion,
the head of the mercenary Wagner Group
as well.
As the heads of the security services
and members of Putin's own party.
These two groups align in their belief
that Putin is mishandling the war effort
a terrifying reality that
seems to emerge from this picture
is that Putin,
a man who started Europe's
biggest land war since World War Two.
A man
whose policies are nothing
short of extreme
in the eyes of the world,
is far less radical
than the warmongering elite
in his own country.
Son a view paints
a worrying portrait of governance
far from the sure footed,
centralized, vicious regime.
Many in the West have come to nurture
in their imaginations
she tells The New Yorker
that arrests are carried out
by multiple agencies,
sometimes without Putin's knowledge.
Putin's own decisions appear confused,
based on which competing faction
influences him at the moment,
and Putin's view
can be at odds with his own agencies.
For example,
Putin sees Prigozhin as a hero
even as the federal security services
and technocrats view him as a threat.
Putin also
faces more
severe economic pressures
than is widely believed
The Wall Street
Journal reported this week
that pollution data belies
the Kremlin's claim
that its industrial
production is recovering.
Pollution in industrial regions
has dropped 6.2%
over the past year,
more than during the peak
of the pandemic.
Russian official statistics
claim that annual industrial production
actually rose by 1.2% in March.
And Jeff Sonnenfeld, a professor
at the Yale School of Management,
has pointed out
that Russia's energy
revenue is down
as a result of the G7 price
cap on Russian oil.
Meanwhile, its budget deficit has soared.
There is one silver lining for Putin.
Whatever Russian elites may think of him,
he is still overwhelmingly popular
with the public.
He has an enviable 83% approval rating,
according to the independent
Levada Center.
Moreover,
the public does support
his ill considered war.
But according to Stan, a via that support
just gives cover to increase repression.
It also keeps elites
who may privately oppose the war
from speaking out.
The danger is not that
the Putin regime may collapse from within
she says.
But that even under him,
it could transform
into something
monstrous, ruthless, inhumane.
A reign of fear
as bad as the
Putin regime looks now in Russia.
It could actually get worse.